tout au long de l'année le bibliobus
anime des rencontres lectures avec les
responsables des centres de
documentation des collèges et des lycées
sur l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines plusieurs auteurs se déplace à
cette occasion dans des classes de
troisième et de seconde c'est le cas
notamment de xavier deutsch bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être venu donc sur ce
plateau hauteur de11 l'histoire d'une
équipe de football amateur qui va défier
les plus grands clubs et les plus
grandes équipes et puis depuis
aujourd'hui donc et jusqu'au 18 janvier
vous échangez avec ses différents
lecteurs élèves de troisième et de
seconde on va en parler et puis bon soit
également armé les rv et vous êtes
bibliothécaire assistante de
conservation au centre de ressources
pour les professionnels de l'enfance ase
voilà pour votre titre complet bonsoir à
vous comment se sont déroulées ces
premiers échanges vous étiez ce matin
avec des élèves des longs cours et cet
après midi à voisins bretons 9 voilà ça
s'est très très bien passé moi je suis
vraiment ravi d'être d'abord d'être dans
les yvelines qui était un département ne
connaissais pas du tout d'être ici à
saint quentin en yvelines pour toute la
semaine et de rencontrer des publics
dans les collèges les lycées c'est pour
moi chaque fois une expérience qui est
un petit peu déroutante en même temps
pour laquelle j'ai beaucoup d'appétit
parce que je rencontre des lycéens des
collégiens qui ont pas mal de choses à
m'apprendre qui ont parfois des
questionnements des interrogations
surprenante donc moi je suis vraiment
ravi d'être là quel type de questions
par exemple surprenante on nous a posé
et il y en a une qui vous a marqué avec
quelques-unes qui vont marquer on me
demande
par mail
elle a des souvenirs puisqu'elle est
présente lors des rencontres bon on me
demande on m'a demandé notamment de
quelle manière j'avais rencontré ma
femme on m'a demandé alors c'est par le
moins surprenant on me demande quel est
le roman où le livre que j'emporterais
sur une île déserte rafale l est puis
alors il ya des questions plus pointues
sur le roman lui-même ce que je préfère
c'est que lorsqu'on ne pose une question
qui révèle une interprétation une
lecture un aspect que je n'avais pas vu
sur mon propre roman c'est ce qu'il ya
pour moi plus intéressés lorsque tout à
coup il ya des lecteurs qui me révèle
quelque chose que je connaissais pas sur
mon propre roman c'est ce que vous
attendiez oui en moi une attente
particulière j'attends de ces rencontres
qu elle m'étonne qu'elle me surprennent
qu'elle me ravit ce qu'elle me fasse
aller sur des chemins que j'avais pas
prévu au départ et ça arrive plus une
fois donc je suis vraiment ravi et ça va
durer donc jusqu'au 18 janvier pourquoi
avoir décidé d'initier ce rendez vous
avec les auteurs de les faire venir dans
des classes je pense que ça apporte
beaucoup aux élèves je ne me dira pas ce
que ça peu précisément leur apporter
mais c'est vrai que c'est c'est toujours
un événement même si xavier deutsch se
dit un écrivain qui exercent un métier
tout à fait anodin normal ça reste
toujours une
événement malgré tout pour pour les
élèves de de rencontrer un auteur de
chair et d'os qui a écrit comme le livre
qu'ils ont entre les mains et qui les a
fait voyager qu'ils y voilà et ces
rencontres ce projet a débuté dans le
cadre des rencontres lectures et c'est
bien ça qui ont lieu entre des
professionnels enseignants des
professionnels du livre professionnels
du livre on se réunit régulièrement
toutes les six ou huit semaines et
l'idée de ces rencontres c'est de
discuter autour des ouvrages de
littérature
étiqueté jeunesse ou pour adolescents ou
de la littérature générale mais le but
c'est vraiment qu'on est au minimum de
rencontre sur un même ouvrage puisqu'on
à chaque lecteur à son regard et
et de faire passer ce ces ouvrages
vous adolescents qu'ils prennent plaisir
comme on a pu prendre plaisir nous si
nous aussi à la lecture vous écrire
aussi bien pour les adolescents pour les
adultes gilles masson décrire
différentes pour les pour les enfants
pour les plus jeunes en tout cas pour
les adolescents surtout pas dire enfants
les adolescents n'ont d'ailleurs pas
remué leurs mots dont on parle
maintenant onze qui comme vous l'avez
dit évoque un match de football une demi
finale de coupe d'europe c'est un roman
que j'avais écrit et que j'avais proposé
à des éditeurs généralistes qui les ont
refusés jusqu'à ce que je finisse par la
dresser un éditeur jeunesse qui l'a
acceptée mais c'est pour vous dire qu'au
départ moi je l'avais écrit comme un
roman point à la ligne pour adultes 20
pour adultes en tout cas ou non mais en
tout cas sans vous soucier du lectorat
véritablement sens celui là comme je
continue de penser qu'un boulanger fait
du pain d'un boulanger fait du pain il
se pose pas la question de savoir si le
pain qui cuit qu'il met en vente va être
consommée par un enfant un adolescent
une personne âgée un adulte il fait du
pain moi j'écris des romans je me pose
pas la question de savoir entre lehmann
qui il va tomber puis suit sur sa route
mais là en l'occurrence ce livre 11 qui
a l'apparence d'être un roman pour
adolescents il peut très bien être lus
par n'importe lequel des lecteurs
adultes du département de ses alentours
oui parce que vous évoquez des questions
qui forcément intéresse tout le monde et
tout le monde peut s'y retrouver un
dépassement de soi rapports humains au
delà de l'aspect sportif véritablement
oui puis l'aspect sportif et les voilà
dans la en régie pour le moment il ya
des footballeur qui attendent de vous
rejoindre sur le plateau et l'aspect
sportif ça important indépendamment des
valeurs que ça véhicule c'est de
l'énergie et de la puissance l'histoire
du football depuis quelques dizaines
d'années elle comporte des exploits
extraordinaires le football pas que le
sport général pour moi le vendée globe
c'est un épisode mythique de l'histoire
humaine une coupe du monde de rugby sac
chose de dingue il ya des courses
cyclistes qui atteignent parfois des
valeurs d'épopée de légende sadia
mythique il ya des matchs de foot quand
une valeur colossale
littéraire c'est quelque chose qui vous
passionne le sport ça vous inspire
véritablement dans l'écriture la la
visite est le premier roman que vous
écriviez autour du sport c'est le
premier roman que j'écris qui touche un
événement sportif l'avim passionnant
tout ce que la puissance de vie brand
lumineux de grand dans ce qu elle
capable de nous en pl et un match de
foot peut nous emporter au loin de
manière puissante voix la vie entière me
passionne vous qui avait assisté aux
différentes rencontres qui ont lieu déjà
aujourd'hui et puis ça se poursuit
encore à travers saint quentin en
yvelines jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
vous en avez pensé quoi de la nature des
échanges avec les adolescents les plus
jeunes parler de deschamps surprenant
quelquefois mais par rapport au thème
également est ce qu'ils se montrent très
réceptifs parce que ça touche le monde
du sport ex forcément peut-être savez
touche plus ça touche le monde du sport
mais je crois que le roman il va
effectivement au delà du simple match de
foot nous quand on en a quand on en
discute et quand on l'a présenté on a
présenté ça comme une aventure humaine
le fait que chaque chaque joueur de
cette petite équipe d'amateurs puiseaux
puise au fond de lui même les l'énergie
pour voilà pour relever le défi qui leur
est imposée c'est à la fois
individuellement puis à la fois
collectivement comment cette cette
montée en puissance collective à la riva
l'avouent ils en sont arrivés là par des
quoi de ces différentes rencontres pour
les pour les plus jeunes que salée que
ça les touche qu'à un moment donné le
roman qui a été lu
voilà envie de lire tout simplement
peut-être oui enfin qu'ils aient envie
de dire qu'ils aient passé un bon moment
et que si ça peut leur donner envie de
dire autre chose et tant mieux aussi
pour ceux qui l'ont lu pour partie si ça
peut leur donner envie de poursuivre la
lecture ou voilà qu'ils disaient qu'ils
aient pris un moment de plaisir à se
poser et à lire d'autres auteurs sont
attendus dans les prochains mois
là il faut demander à la communauté
d'agglomération qui qui me permet de
financer une fois par an elle avait vu
et puis ces saignées aussi haut on va
dire au travail des participants de
rencontrer les classes les professeurs
s'implique également pour unir pour
travailler autour de ces ouvrages pour
qu'ensuite vous aussi des questions
autre que comment avez vous rencontré
votre femme par exemple
les questions qu'on pose j'imagine que
pour le garçon qui me posent cette
question là il ya quelque chose là
dessus il envie de vérifier que chez un
normal que j'ai rencontré ma femme pas
sur le pont d'ain transatlantique ni sur
la planète mars mais comme tout le monde
et auteur les écrivains sont comme tout
le monde voilà c'est ça ça me paraît
important c'est pour rassurer les plus
jeunes merci donc d'être revenue sur ce
plateau xavier deutsch en rappel ce
livre 11 et puis à l'autre ouvrage le
dernier ouvrage qui a été publié c'était
au début de l'année au coin de la rue
des amours également voilà au coin de la
rue des amours par un éditeur belge
qu'est ce que vous êtes belge n'a pas
précisé c'est voilà on l'a dit merci à
vous merci également à armer les revêt
donc d'être passé sur ce plateau est les
rencontres avec les jeunes des lycées
des collèges de saint quentin qui vont
se poursuivre retour sur cette
information donc du jour la
manifestation contre le mariage pour
tous qui a également mobilisé dans le
département avec des départs organisé
depuis saint quentin en yvelines et puis
juste après le 7-8 sport le point
complet 26 minutes sur l'actualité
sportive
à paris la manifestation contre le
mariage pour tous a rassemblé 340 mille
personnes selon la police et 800 mille
selon les organisateurs
dans le département des départs groupés
ont été organisées ce dimanche comme à
la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
xavier manifeste pour la première fois
pour demander un débat au plan national
ce qui le choque c'est le mot mariage
le terme de mariage le mot mariage pour
moi est attaché à l'union d'un homme et
d'une femme est donc je verrais bien que
les parlementaires votent une loi où il
attribue les mêmes droits aux hommes aux
homosexuels dans le cadre d'une union
civile mais pas avec le mot mariage une
trentaine de personnes patientent pour
prendre le chemin de la manifestation
parisienne dans une ambiance sereine pas
de banderoles j'ai pas trop l'habitude
de manifester mais c'est vrai que ça
m'intéresse
se défend de la famille c'est important
pour moi et c'est vrai que c'est un
un des domaines qui me tient à coeur
particulièrement quoi elle a rien contre
contre les homosexuels ils font ce
qu'ils veulent mais les enfants on
besoin d'un père et d'une mère à l'écart
du groupe de militants tiennent une
pancarte explicite on est venu essayer
de le redonner un peu le sourire avec
des affiches caricature le débat actuel
je trouve qu'ils libèrent paroles
homophobes qu'on croyait endormi et qui
se réveille à l'occasion ce débat et
c'est ça ce qui m'inquiète laurent est
donc favorable au mariage pour tous il
sera aux côtés des partisans au projet
de loi dimanche 27 janvier